bonjour thomas vous êtes à washington un
sommet qui a été particulièrement scruté
de ce côté là également quel bilan
pouvez vous tirer de ce déplacement
outre-atlantique
et bien c'est avec le sentiment du
devoir accompli que joe biden a atterri
il ya quelques instants ici aux etats
unis j'ai fait ce que j'étais venu faire
voilà ce qu'a déclaré joe biden à
l'issue de son périple en europe on sait
son voyage avait été très longuement
préparé très minutieusement préparé il
avait emmené avec lui un certain nombre
de ses conseillers ainsi que son
secrétaire d'état
anthony blinken on a d'ailleurs pu
apercevoir les antisèches de joe biden
au moment où il ya eu 7 ce moment ouvert
à la presse au sein de la ville à la
grange alors du côté de la presse on est
évidemment plutôt clément avec joe biden
même dithyrambique en expliquant qu'il y
avait enfin le retour d'une véritable
diplomatie américaine on a même eu le
droit à certains articles qui nous
expliquait que joe biden avait gagné
contre vladimir poutine comme s'il
s'agissait d'un combat de boxe ou d'un
match de football alors il s'appuie pour
cela sur le body language la gestuelle
des deux présidents c'est d'ailleurs le
genre d' analyse qu'on a pu voir tout au
long de la journée ici aux etats-unis
avec parfois une mauvaise foi assez
déconcertante il faut bien le dire mais
par exemple un journaliste de cnn qui a
possédé capture d'écran de la rencontre
entre vladimir poutine et joe biden
notamment lors de la poignée de main
expliquant que vladimir poutine avait
détourné le regard face à joe biden ou
encore que l'atmosphère était
particulièrement pesant au sein de la
ville à la grange alors qu'en réalité
lorsqu'on regardait à l'intégralité des
images l'analyse qu'on pouvait faire de
cette de cet événement était très
différente mais évidemment le moment qui
a été le plus suivi ici c'était donc la
conférence de presse de joe biden la
volonté des équipes de la maison blanche
était d'éviter de faire une conférence
de presse conjointe pour éviter les
critiques qu'avaient reçu donald trump à
l'époque en 2018 pour justement avoir
fait cet exercice
alors la conférence de presse de joe
biden était millimétré très près par et
peut-être même un peu trop parce que la
sensation qu'on avait c'est qu'on avait
d'un côté vladimir poutine qui a passé
par quasiment une heure à répondre à pas
mal de questions de journalistes russes
mais aussi de journalistes étrangers
dont des journalistes américains et puis
de l'autre côté on avait joe biden qui a
d'abord lu un discours pendant une
dizaine de minutes sur son prompteur
avant de répondre à environ sept
questions de journalistes uniquement
américain et les questions qu'ils
avaient été choisis au préalable et
d'ailleurs au moment où joe biden a
quitté la conférence de presse qu'il a
remis sa veste qu'il a remis ses
lunettes de soleil il y avait encore des
questions qui fusaient de la part des
journalistes qui étaient présents
et ça a créé un petit incident à un
moment parce qu'il ya une passe d'armes
entre joe biden est une journaliste de
cnn
au point que joe biden a finalement
présenté ses excuses un peu plus tard
lorsqu'il était sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport de genève avant de prendre
son avion
là encore il y avait des journalistes
qui l'attendaient qui lui ont posé des
questions quelles garanties at il que
les engagements pris par vladimir
poutine seront respectés écoutez la
réponse de jobs hayden
quelles preuves concrètes avez-vous
depuis trois heures ou plus qui vous
laissent penser que les choses ont bougé
pour être un bon journaliste il faut
être négatif il faut avoir une vision
négative de la vie c'est comme ça que je
vois les choses c'est cette façon que
vous avez tous vous ne posez jamais de
questions positive pourquoi parce que
nous avons un accord nous verrons bien
nous avons un accord pour travailler sur
un accord majeur de contrôle des armes
j'ai commencé à travailler sur des
accords de contrôle d un pendant la
guerre froide
si on peut le faire pendant la guerre
froide pourquoi pas maintenant nous
verrons bien
nous verrons si cela se produit ou non
et qu'en est-il tout va des réactions
politiques est ce que joe biden a
convaincu si vous écoutez les démocrates
qui vous diront que oui ils sont
évidemment dithyrambique sur le
président démocrate joe biden ils
reprennent en réalité la rhétorique qui
est la sienne depuis plusieurs jours
maintenant à savoir l'amérique est de
retour c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a tout
l'été joe biden à bord d'air force one
lors de son retour ici aux etats-unis en
expliquant que les alliances entre les
etats-unis et les pays occidentaux
n'avaient jamais été aussi forte
mais vous pouvez vous en douter du côté
des républicains on est un peu plus
critique notamment contre joe biden et
contre le manque de fermeté en tout cas
c'est ce que disent les rêves c'est un
certain nombre d'élus républicains ici
manque de fermeté envers vladimir
poutine
parmi les personnalités qui sont
exprimées tout au long de la journée on
a notamment pu voir mike pompéo l'ancien
chef de la diplomatie de donald trump ou
encore nikki haley qui a été envoyée la
représentante des états unis au sein de
l'organisation des nations-unies et puis
il ya aussi eu donald trump qui s'est
exprimé en fin en début de soirée sur
l'antenne de fox news lui aussi s'est
montré très critique contre son
successeur notamment contre la décision
de son successeur de ne pas condamner
plus fermement le projet de gazoduc
north stream 2 donald trump a expliqué
aux autres pendant cette interview que
s'il a eu la même posture que celle de
japan aujourd'hui les médias qui
encensent aujourd'hui joe biden l'aurait
lui vivement critiqué on est donc de
nouveau face aux clivages assez
classique assez traditionnel ici aux
etats-unis entre les démocrates et les
républicains mais on sait les électeurs
américains ne juge pas vraiment leur
président sur sa politique interne
sonal au moins tant qu'il n'y a pas de
faux pas majeur et joe biden qui est
donc de retour aux etats-unis va devoir
très vite se pencher sur les dossiers
internes du pays des dossiers très
compliqués qu'ils attendent ici l'un
d'entre eux c'est la gestion de la
frontière sud des états unis avec le
mexique
et preuve que le dossier est très
important et bien donald trump encore
lui a annoncé il ya quelques temps qu'il
allait se rendre à la frontière d'ici
quelques jours et on va suivre cela
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de washington